I am not asking the Commissioners for
blind obedience
as I said in Brussels when
I presented the college at my age one does
not start a career as a dictator
but I would like
the Commissioners
to be free we asked the President-
designate  of the Commission to do everything
to be able to compose a
political college so respect the fact that
Commissioners have
political opinions and feed
the debates within the Commission through reflection
I have a contract with you, Mr
President, and with the European Parliament
and i intend to abide by the terms of the
contract which i have set out before you
was in the current year
i have read
in most of the European newspapers
that Franz steamand will be my right hand
i hope from time to time he will
also my left hand but it will be
difficult
I would like the European Union to
find
and equip itself with another triple eye I
would like Europe and the triple and
social the triple is social is as
important as the economic triple eye
j  I had to fight to get to see the
national government offered me 9
women but to tell the truth nine women out of
28 commissioners remain ridiculous
I had no
idea and those who know me the
sapper of a fine that the drugs
that the  health products that
medical activity itself would be a
commodity like any other
health is not a commodity
and therefore sensitive to the call that was
made to me to restore order in this
distribution of skills
it was a  wish expressed during the
parliamentary hearings this was a
wish largely taken up by a good
part of the medical professions i have
decided to reassign his powers to the
Health Commissioner
i do not want to deceive people nor
the peoples do not give the impression to
those who are paid candidates that they
could become a member of the
European Union over the next five years
there will be no new members
during the term of this commission it
is strictly not feasible
the European Union could be
credible cannot be a
deadbeat the European Union must honor
its commitments
the ebola crisis requires a
strong, rapid, organized and concentrated reaction from
the European Union I do not have
the impression that we have been up to the
task  when it comes to
combating this epidemic, the problems linked
to illegal migration and
legal migration will be treated as
real priorities by the
commission which I hope to take
office on 1
November my conviction that this
commission will be the Commission  of the
last chance
we succeed in bringing
European citizens closer to Europe or we
fail I would like us to seize
this chance to get things moving and
Europe deserves it and I am counting on you,
Mr President, Ladies and Gentlemen,
to support the Commission in  these
multiple tasks which are in front of us
which are in front of you and which are in front of
the Europeans I thank you for your
attention